a video that recently went viral from  Tick Tock seems to have captured this  phenomenon perhaps better than anything  else we've seen uh here it is you're not  one of the good white people there are  no good white people there are only  anti-racist white people and racist  white people anti-racism is a lifelong  project and the end goal is not for you  to be good it's for society to be good  decenter yourself stop patting yourself  on the back stop congratulating each  other stop separating us from the bad  white people don't sit out there in  comments and say we don't claim them we  are them we are the ones shooting up  schools we are the ones raping people we  are the ones enslaving people we're them  speak for yourself lady I have in fact  never done any of those things and uh of  the people who have done them they are  not exclusively white not even close